[Musique]
la secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées sophie cluzel s'est rendu à
la maison départementale des personnes
handicapées de la réunion
accompagné du président du département
elle a pu échanger avec des familles et
des représentants d'associations
la secrétaire d'état a rappelé
l'engagement du gouvernement pour
améliorer la prise en charge et
l'accompagnement personnalisé du
handicap ou mettant des droits avis je
tiens à le signer le plus 1er janvier
plus besoin de revenir tous les deux ans
trois ans quatre ans pour obtenir son
allocation adulte handicapé quand on a
un handicap à 80 % qui malheureusement
ne va pas s'améliorer et donc les
équipes sont justement totalement
orientés vers ces droits vie qui vont
permettre de libérer du temps pour
justement faire des nouveaux métiers
d'assembleur de solutions comme on dit
souvent avec le directeur dame des
neiges le lendemain sophie cluzel a
rencontré une famille d'accueil à bras
panon marie-françoise aux ide habite ici
depuis deux ans avec la famille ragoût
20 c à sécréter tué gatti viendra milk
et mickey c'est une volonté du
département dont de faire ensemble que
l'accueil familial reste on va dire
entre nîmes et le numéro à à la réunion
parce que nous voyons bien ça fait
partie du bien vieillir et la personne
s'y sent bien
la réunion est le premier département
français à offrir autant de places
d'accueil en famille un modèle de
solidarité souligné par la secrétaire
d'état
[Musique]